in this video we'll talk about
systemic lupus erythematosus
systemic means involving multiple organs
and erythematosus means reddening of the
skin
so let's see what are the disease
pathology signs and symptom and the
genetic and environmental cause
systemic lupus is an autoimmune disease
which involves multiple organs
and anti-nuclear antibodies are the key
cause of these disease
the characteristic of this disease is a
worst array of anti-nuclear antibodies
or amas
and one of the
feature of this disease is a butterfly
shaped malar rash on the cheeks
now females are more susceptible
to systemic lupus erythematosus
anyone can develop systemic lupus but
there are some disposition in female
that make them more vulnerable
in fact 9 out of 10 people
with lupus are women
now there is a gender bias of systemic
lupus
and many of the genes or risk genes are
associated in the x chromosome
and also
there are hormonal factors which can
attribute to this bias
the prevalence of this disease
is two to threefold higher in blacks and
hispanics compared to whites
so overall there is a strong genetic
predisposition of lupus
now let's talk about what really happens
in the systemic lupus
so the systemic lupus is characterized
by these immune complexes
so these immune complexes are made up of
anti-nuclear
antigens and specific antibodies against
them
and all these immune complexes leads to
various autoimmune effects and immune
reactions
all of these are characterized as type 3
hypersensitivity
reaction and which is very common is in
systemic lupus
so all these immune complexes are
deposited on several
places such as skin or in epithelial
layers
and these
immune complexes attract
an um specific cell type such as
dendritic cell macrophages or
neutrophils all of these cells can
secrete several cytokines which are
inflammatory in nature
and overall lead to a huge inflammation
in that particular tissue
now
injury of skin
joints and kidney
is very common and prominent in systemic
lupus
now question is why auto antibodies are
produced in systemic lupus arithmetosis
now generally our immune system protects
our body from any type type of harmful
pathogen
so whenever a pathogen lets say a virus
enters our body
specific antibodies are generated
against the virus which code the virus
and inactivates it
generally our immune cells does not
produce antibody against our own cells
let's say epithelial cell
and this is known as tolerance but this
tolerance mechanism is perturbed in case
of systemic lupus erythematosus
and autoreactive b cells or plasma cells
are produced which secretes antibody
against our own cells
so let's discuss the genetic risk of
systemic lupus
now there are specific alleles such as
hla dq
which has been reported to be highly
associated with the onset of systemic
lupus
now there are many other uh
antibodies which are generated in
systemic lupus such as antiphospholipid
antibodies
anti-antibodies against double-stranded
dna etc
now some of the lupus patients have
inherited deficiencies in complement
cascade molecules such as
c 4 or c 1 q
and all of these complement system can
also lead to cellular destruction
now lack of complement system may impair
the removal of circulating immune
complexes
complement systems are really important
to clear up immune complexes
so genetic sequencing found that there
are many many genes which are associated
or can be considered to be the risk
factor genes of systemic lupus and all
of these genes belong to the category
like immune complex processing immune
signal transduction and tlr type 1
interferon pathway related genes etc
now there are several drugs that can
also lead to lupus or can
are shown to induce lupus-like symptoms
such as
all of these drugs noted here
now there are other environmental risk
factors associated with lupus as well
one of the common environmental risk
factor is uv radiation so when there is
uv radiation it it leads to
damage in our cells so some of the cells
would undergo apoptosis
there would be irreversible and
irreparable dna damage which would
ultimately lead to apoptosis or death of
these cells
now these cells would eject its all its
nuclear compound components and
everything
so those nuclear components would be now
treated as damage associated molecular
patterns which can be recognized by
cells like dendritic cells which has
told like certain tone like receptors on
them
and these dendritic cells can eventually
display the antigens
that mean the antigens of the self
cells onto their surface
it can present it to
cells like
t cells which make them autoreactive
ultimately it can also lead to
activation of these autoreactive b cells
which secretes antibody against own body
cells
so as a result what happens is there are
auto antibodies and immune complexes
which attracts different other cell
types which evokes the inflammatory
responses and this is how damages happen
in systemic lupus
now we understand why these anti
antigens are known as antinuclear
antigens and
the antibodies are really important in
the development of lupus
all of these immune complexes can
circulate throughout the body
and also it can be deposited in the
blood vessels which can attract
neutrophils and thereby damaging the
blood vessels itself
now sometimes
there are specific carbohydrates present
in the
rbc membrane also there are specific
phospholipids
which are present in the rbc membrane
are detected by these auto antibodies
and this leads to like complement
mediated lysis
and
this leads to damage of these rbcs
and that is why
a lot of rbc cells are
damaged
during lupus which can explain that
reddening of the skin part
now let's talk about the clinic clinical
manifestation of the lupus so clinical
manifestation of lupus is highly highly
variable different patient shows
different kind of signs and symptoms
so here are some list of that
on the left hand side you can see
clinical manifestation and you can see
prevalence in patients
so
one feature is very common
all these hematologic complications
reddening of the skin lysis of rbc these
things are very prevalent in all the
patients almost hundred percent patients
with lupus show these kind of problems
other than that arthritis is present in
80 percent skin lesions are shown in 85
percent fever is present in 55 55
fatigue is present in 80 percent
renal complication in 60 to 70 percent
pleurities in 45 percent
pericarditis in 25 percent
gastrointestinal complications in 20 and
peripheral neuropathy is observed in 15
percent
so many of these symptoms are
variable from patient to patient
now let's talk about
how lupus could be detected
and what does antinuclear antigen means
or antinuclear antibody means so
antinuclear antibodies can be detected
using
a test known as anna
so in this ana test is actually a blood
test
and several cell lines such as hep two
cell lines are used for these ana tests
hepta cell lines are specially chosen
because these cells has
hundreds of antigens which mimics the
antinuclear antigens
and that could be detected by these
anti-nuclear antibodies so in simple
words if a patient sample has
anti-nuclear antibodies it would detect
the
antigens on the hip to cells there is al
alternative possibility which is no
anti-nuclear antibodies present in the
patient sample in that case there would
be no detection
okay after that secondary antibodies are
added to these samples which would
ultimately allow us to understand the
immunofluorescence pattern
so immunofluorescence pattern is
actually
immunofluorescence pattern is actually
the determination factor of these tests
in short presence of immunofluorescence
is actually a measure for the anarchist
now a scientist can look scientist or a
medical individual can look at different
anti-nuclear antibody pattern and can
guess about
the disease
so let's see how to interpret the ana
result so if the pattern is homogeneous
most likely the individual might have
systemic lupus rheumatic rheumatoid
arthritis or something
and all these other patterns such as
speckled peripheral or nuclear pattern
has other interpretation
so anna test is basically a fundamental
screening method it's not a confirmatory
test
additional blood tests need to be done
in order to understand or diagnose
systemic lupus
and if ana test is positive that means
you might have some amount of
anti-nuclear antibodies but further test
has to be performed
so that pretty much summarize the videos
that pretty much summarize the concept
of
ana and
systemic lupus erythematosus in this
video if you want more notes regarding
this you can watch my facebook page you
can follow me on instagram you can
support my channel using the super like
option
anyway you can get dynamic flash cards
in the facebook page
and you can also access my course in
academy which is india's biggest online
learning platform using a code